so if I understand correctly ladies that
the two of you passed around ina may
Gaskin this book spiritual midwifery
between the two of you and friends and
so you knew her as someone in in that
community and then Sarah you saw her at
an event in LA and a poster yeah i'm-a
came through town and was staying in my
doulas house and my doula called me up I
had like a three-month-old in my arms
and my doula called up and said you'll
never guess who's at my house ima come
over tonight and meet her and so I
showed up and an item a was sitting at
the kitchen table you know like this
great heroin that like you know I had
admired for so long and there were lots
of doulas and people from the Los
Angeles birth community there but nobody
was talking to my Anna Mae
I think because she was so because she's
such an important figure people were
like a little shy like you know they
just hadn't quite nobody was like
engaging with her she was sort of busy
working and so I just like got the
current it was like one of those things
where you do something that you don't it
doesn't seem like you would do but I
just walked right up and said like you
know what's up about what's going on
with the documentary was there ever been
one about you and she's like no and then
I got home and called Mary and said
you'll never guess who I met last night
there was no documentary about her she
seems amenable and Mary's like let's
let's go do it and so we just click
through through her back you know it was
like a couple months later we just we've
packed ourselves off anywhere it's
Tennessee
you